[Musique]
depuis que je suis petit je regarde
cette cérémonie
chaque année je voudrais les enveloppes
dans ma tête une à une
depuis mon canapé alors payet en
amérique est au je te reconnais tes
meilleurs sons vous êtes toujours 3es
vos discours sont très longs je voudrais
remercier michel moi aussi je voudrais
remercier mes schémas normalement
maintenant remercier michel tout à
l'heure et pas longtemps les meilleurs
remerciements
c'est ce qui dure le moins longtemps on
décidera français et anglais tous ici ce
soir
d'accord pour dire qu'on aime tous jean
pierre
et je déclare ouverte la 43e cérémonie
des césars navel thérèse biscaye
l'intérêt collectif
mais voilà qu'on se retrouve à concourir
arnaud quel paradoxe les prix bon merci
cohen avant je crois que c'est clair
pour tout le monde
les producteurs n'ont plus le droit de
violer les actrices et par compte y ait
quelque chose qui n'est pas clair et qui
va falloir clarifier je pense assez vite
c est ce que nous on a encore le droit
de coucher pour avoir les rôles
camélia jordana dans le vrai en est
dingue
merci découvrons ensemble les nommer
pour cette catégorie du meilleur compte
instagram alice belaïdi pour l'ensemble
de sa collection pose naturelle au bord
de l'eau pierre niney pour terminer by
pierre niney arnaud rebotini dont 120
dans un bâtiment je dédie ce prix à ces
oubliés d'hier et d'aujourd'hui
act up exige toujours que nous sida
n'est pas qu'un film merci et vous
faites ensemble on tape le disent très
fort qu'en fait de remettre le césar
18 bien
je vous remercie nos jeunes femmes non
joueurs banon je vous remercie pas vous
mireille darc nous fait penser à mes
adapté fou n'importe quoi voilà je vais
vous dire que j'ai décidé de sortir du
placard des légendes comme stefan c'est
super sauf qu'on a dit qu'on aurait été
de dire les primes mais stéphane dupré
son prénom se sentent sous l'eau
embrassez moi car compliqué cette série
à
[Musique]
période ce soir je tresse envie de
remercier la ville antoine renard si
c'est vraiment très très sympa
[Musique]
j'ai perdu tout ce qu'on a pu mais rld
je suis très heureuse de retrouver ma
famille de cinéma sara giraudeau dans
petit paysan et je vous embrasse tous
parce que c'est sacrément beau lui d'ici
voilà là d'être là devant vous c'est
très impressionnant
vous qui m'avez fait mais le cinéma clan
dirait un peu que c'est mon anniversaire
merci abonnés à canal+ pour l'occasion
ça ira sans la flandre par la courbe
remonte
tu peut réinvestir dans le cinéma 11
belhout albert jeanne balibar marina
aussi de ria que je connais moi et nous
traversons nos vie d'actrice ensemble
depuis un bon moment maintenant
et quelle joie quelle fierté de partager
ce césar 2018 avec vous 120 battre
mentalement je sais que c'est ceux qui
se sont battus avons nous le droit de
pouvoir va parler devant vous ce soir je
sens parfois une inquiétude face au
soulèvement des femmes qui réclament le
droit la justice et l égalité
n'ayons pas peur de ce qui arrive tout
va bien se passer
ce mouvement n'est pas une menace mais
c'est une promesse et l'histoire nous
dira que nous avions raison
merci beaucoup ainsi s'achève cette 43e
cérémonie des césar ce que je viens de
dire est pour moi
à bientôt prenez soin de vous et bonsoir
jean pierre mathis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]